in the last video we figured out the
absolute minimum speed in order to stay
on the circular path right over here
especially near the top was
27.6 kilometers per hour what i want to
do in this video is i just want to clip
i just clipped out the parts where he's
actually on the loop to loop and i want
to actually figure out his average
velocity so i'm going to use the video
editor right here to time how long it
takes to complete the loop the loop and
then we can use that and what we know
about the circumference of this loop the
loop and we're going to assume that it
is perfectly circular for our
assumptions although it looks like it's
a little bit egg shaped in reality or a
little bit elliptical but for our
calculations we're going to assume that
it is perfectly circular and i'll leave
it to you to think about how it would
change if you had an elliptical shape
like this so with that other way let's
watch the video again remember this is
from fifth gear which shows on the
channel five in the united kingdom
so there you go let's watch it again
that's just fun to watch there you go
and right over here we have the little
timer for my video editor and this right
here over here is in seconds and i was
corrected on an earlier video this right
over here is not in hundreds of seconds
this is in frames and there's 30 frames
per second so it starts at
0 seconds 0 frames and then when we play
it it goes to 2 seconds and 14 frames
but that's 30 frames per second so it's
2 and 14 30 of a second is how long it
takes this car to do the loop
so two that's one second and then two
seconds two and fourteen thirty so
almost two and a half seconds so let's
write that down
so the time and this is all rough
because i'm approximating right over
here the time required to do the loop
the loop is 2 and 14 over 30th 2 over 1
14 over 30
seconds and what is the distance that it
traveled if we assume that this thing is
circular although it looks like it's a
little bit more egg shaped if we assume
that it's circular then the distance
traveled is the circumference of the
circular loop the loop the circumference
is 2 pi
times the radius which is equal to 2 pi
and in the previous in the previous
video we figured out that the radius was
6 meters so it's 2 pi times 6 meters
which is equal to
which is equal to 12
pi
meters so if you want to figure out its
average speed i should say the velocity
is constantly changing because the
direction is changing but the magnitude
of the velocity if we want to figure out
the average magnitude of the velocity or
the average speed we would just have to
divide so let me write it over here
average
speed
the total distance traveled is 12 pi
meters
is 12 pi
meters divided by the time required to
travel the 12 pi meters so that is 2 and
14 over 30
2 and 14 over 30 seconds now let's get
our calculator out to actually calculate
that value
so we're going to have the distance is
let me clear this so we have 12 pi
meters divided by
let's write this as 2 plus
14 divided by 30 just to get the exact
value
2 divide plus 14 divided by 30 and then
this gives us in meters per second
meters per second 15 point i'll just go
with 15.3 meters per second so the
average speed is approximately 15.3
15.3 meters per second which is almost
which is almost twice as fast as we
figured out that minimum speed it had to
be and that's because you want that
margin of safety and you want to be able
to have some traction with the road
although you don't want to go too fast
because then the g forces are going to
be too big then this and maybe we'll
talk about that in a future video but
just to relate this into kilometers per
hour let's figure out what that is
whoops that's not what i wanted to use i
wanted to use this one right over here
so that's in meters per second let's
figure out how many meters per hour by
multiplying by 3 600 seconds per hour so
that's how many meters per hour divided
by a thousand which you can kind of see
right over there
that is 55
55 kilometers per hour and if you wanted
to do it in miles a rough approximation
divided by 1.6 it's about 35 miles per
hour give or take or 55 kilometers per
hour so this is this is approximately 55
kilometers per hour so the driver here
luckily they did the physics problem
ahead of time and he had the margin of
safety he was well in excess of the
minimum velocity just to maintain the
circular motion so he probably had some
nice traction with the track up here